yeah that same jujitsu concept okay
so when he comes in you're gonna make
contact right
but don't try something here okay
he's gonna do something else you see
he's gonna do something
you got it so he's trying for at least
time for this
trying to get stuff from an adult
you need to make contact because i'll
put you in you're gonna do something
else okay and you do have to do
something you can't just be here
but you're not going to try to get
something either okay
you're going to wait for him to do
something he will do something
okay oh you're home
just be
[Music]
take away your support
okay
all right um so with the jiu-jitsu
strategy
is that i am trying to minimize how much
energy i need to input in order to
achieve the desired force
okay so the strategy is
uh you go you go first and i
i respond to and with what you're doing
okay
that that's how you
do non-contestation i can't
non-contest if i'm trying to force
something
okay so as you're trying to grab the
gear
right just go slow you see i make the
the connection but do you feel that okay
so what i'm going to do now
see how i go around that energy you see
that so right here is my strength
and that's where we start pushing in on
each other okay
so you start to go but i go like this
you see and then you're going to do what
what do you want to do so you're going
lower
you see you're going lower you keep
going lower and eventually
[Music]
and then i move with minimum energy to
my position
of advantage okay
so again i have to defend my here
got it so i have to defend my gear with
movement
but see right there is where you're
pushing up on me do you get it
so i don't shut this down wait
and i don't leave my feet here because
that's where we start clashing that's
where people recognize this struggle
so you're trying to do your thing you're
diving and i move
so same thing deviate your eyes were
betraying you
you see now i could go in and force this
because i am technically stronger than
you but in training i don't
every time you push right i use that
thanks
you're not
so initial reaction
[Music]
yielding
up
okay try it again